This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthan. The topic for today's show is one of the most difficult we've ever handled. Why? It's boredom. And it's really hard to make boredom interesting. Social scientists have been studying boredom for many years. Why people get stuck in boring jobs? But now imagine standing there. All day long.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。今天节目的主题是我们处理过最困难的主题之一。为什么？因为是无聊。而要把无聊变得有趣真的很难。社会学家研究无聊已经很多年了。为什么人们会陷入无聊的工作中？但现在想象一下站在那里。一整天。
I cannot imagine a more boring job. How to combat boredom? The reason for a more hot sauce is that lack of sensory stimulation from your environment that you're compensating for it by putting hot sauce on. And the pernicious effects that boredom has on our lives. Boredom some scientists say creates a feeling of meaninglessness. So keep listening, I promise you won't be bored. Really.
我想象不出比这更无聊的工作了。如何对抗无聊？更多的辣椒酱的原因是，你通过放辣椒酱来弥补环境中缺乏的感官刺激。以及无聊对我们生活的有害影响。一些科学家说，无聊会产生一种毫无意义的感觉。所以请继续收听，我向你保证你不会觉得无聊。真的。
In Greek mythology, King Sisyphus is accused by the gods of being vain, avaricious and egotistical. Upon his death, he is condemned to roll a boulder up a hill, watch it roll down the other side, and then repeat the process for all eternity. Now, we've all been there, stuck in repetitious boring jobs, doing boring chores, getting bored in class. Some time ago I spoke with Peter Ubo from Duke University. Along with a colleague David Kymmaferd, Peter studied why people get stuck doing boring work. He asked me to think about applying to be a security guard at a museum.
在希腊神话中，西西弗斯国王被众神指控虚荣、贪婪和自负。死后，他被惩罚把一块巨石推上山，看着它从另一边滚下去，然后永无止境地重复这个过程。现在，我们都经历过这种情况，被困在重复而无聊的工作中，做着无聊的杂务，在课堂上感到无聊。不久前，我采访了杜克大学的彼得·乌博。彼得与同事大卫·基马弗德一起研究了人们为什么会陷入无聊的工作中。他让我考虑申请做博物馆的保安。
At the time, it might sound like a wonderful job. I just stand there and do nothing, and they pay me for it. Wow, that sounds great. But now imagine standing there all day long. While people are walking by the museum and enjoying themselves, you're not even allowed to really talk to them much. I cannot imagine a more boring job. Peter says that when you're anticipating the kind of work involved in a job,
当时，这听起来可能是一份绝佳的工作。我只要站在那里什么都不做，他们就会为此付钱给我。哇，听起来太棒了。但现在想象一下整天站在那里。当人们在博物馆里走来走去并享受乐趣时，你甚至不被允许真正和他们多说话。我想象不出比这更无聊的工作了。彼得说，当你对工作中所涉及的那种工作进行预期时，
you may think about it differently than when you're actually doing the job. Peter says that when you're anticipating the kind of work involved in a job, you may think about it differently than when you're actually doing the job. One rule of thumb we follow in applying for jobs, we often pick work that doesn't involve a lot of effort. The researchers ran an experiment with business students and told the students they had a choice between two jobs. The first job would be to sit in the back row and do nothing. They couldn't look at laptops or cell phones. They had to just look straight ahead. We'd pay them $2.50 for that five minutes. So, money for doing nothing.
你的想法可能与你实际做这项工作时的想法不同。彼得说，当你对工作中所涉及的那种工作进行预期时，你的想法可能与你实际做这项工作时的想法不同。我们在申请工作时遵循的一个经验法则是，我们经常选择不需要付出太多努力的工作。研究人员对商科学生进行了一项实验，告诉学生他们可以在两份工作之间做出选择。第一份工作是坐在最后一排什么也不准做。他们不能看笔记本电脑或手机。他们只能直视前方。这五分钟我们会付给他们2.50美元。所以，这是无所事事的钱。
Or, or they might end up solving word puzzles for that five minutes. Where they'd sit in the front row. And we asked them how much would we have to pay you where you choose the word puzzle over sitting and doing nothing. And we found that the large majority of the students said we'd have to pay them more than $2.50 to solve the word puzzles. Now at one level this makes sense. If someone asks you to work harder, they should pay you more.
或者，他们可能会在这五分钟里解字谜。他们坐在第一排。我们问他们，我们要付给你多少钱，你才会选择解字谜而不是坐在那里什么都不做。我们发现，绝大多数学生表示，我们必须付给他们超过2.50.美元的报酬，他们才愿意去解字谜。现在从某种程度上来说这是有道理的。如果有人要求你更努力地工作，他们应该付给你更多钱。
And yet when we asked them independently, which do you think would be more fun? They said the word puzzles. When we actually finished the five minutes and asked them how much they enjoyed those five minutes, the people solving the word puzzles, enjoyed the five minutes significantly more. And yet very few of them said, yeah, pay me two dollars and I'd be happy to do word puzzles because at least I'll be having fun. Peter calls this tendency of the students to avoid hard work, effort, aversion.
然而，当我们单独问他们时，你认为哪个会更有趣？他们说是字谜。当我们真正完成这五分钟并问他们有多享受这五分钟时，那些解字谜的人对这五分钟的享受程度要高得多。然而，他们中很少有人会说，是的，付给我两美元，我很乐意做字谜游戏，因为至少我会玩得很开心。彼得将学生们避免努力工作的这种倾向称为努力厌恶。
Anything that this is one reason, many people get stuck in boring jobs. A simple rule of thumb, the fancy term is heuristic, led the mystery. More effort should mean more pay is not always true. It isn't just guards who tell people not to touch the paintings who get bored at work. Even jobs that most people would consider to be widely exciting can be boring much of the time. Think about firefighters or soldiers. Also, astronauts.
认为这是许多人陷入无聊工作的原因之一。一个简单的经验法则，高级的说法是启发法，导致了错误。付出更多的努力应该意味着更多的报酬，这并不总是正确的。不仅仅是告诉人们不要触摸画作的保安在工作时会感到无聊。即使是大多数人认为非常刺激的工作，在大部分时间里也可能是无聊的。想想消防员或士兵。还有宇航员。
Max Nestrack from the Hidden Brain team has the story. When NASA sends astronauts into outer space, something strange happens. They use more and more hot sauce. Scientists at NASA got curious about this. One explanation? The absence of gravity causes physical changes in the body, and that weakens your sense of taste. Another idea? Small and close places like spaceships are really stinky.
“隐藏的大脑”团队的马克斯·内斯特拉克将为您讲述这个故事。当美国宇航局将宇航员送入太空时，奇怪的事情发生了。他们使用的辣椒酱越来越多。美国宇航局的科学家对此产生了好奇。一种解释是？重力的缺失会导致身体发生生理变化，从而削弱你的味觉。另一个想法？像飞船这样狭小密闭的地方真的很臭。
Tabasco hides the smell. Then there's boredom. Now, it may be hard to imagine astronauts getting bored, but think about spending weeks looking at the same loose hanging wires, the same floating co-workers, the same blue planet, the same small window. That's where the Tabasco sauce comes in. So one hypothesis for the reason for a more hot sauce is that that lack of sensory stimulation from your environment that you're compensating for it by putting hot sauce on. So yes, there's not a lot of colors in your environment, but you can have colors in your mouth. This is Kim Binstead.
塔巴斯科辣椒酱掩盖了这种气味。还有就是无聊。现在，你可能很难想象宇航员会感到无聊，但想想看，连续几周看着同样松散悬挂的电线、同样漂浮的同事、同样蓝色的星球、同样的小窗户。这就是塔巴斯科辣椒酱发挥作用的地方。因此，关于需要更多辣椒酱的原因的一个假设是，你通过添加辣椒酱来弥补环境中缺乏的感官刺激。所以是的，你的环境中没有太多颜色，但你可以在嘴里拥有颜色。这是金·宾斯特德。
She's a professor at the University of Hawaii. And she studies the psychological effects of long-term spaceflight. And this is a subject that's really important to NASA, because they want to send astronauts to Mars in the next 20 years. Binstead's job is to figure out how to keep the astronauts healthy. And she's found that boredom isn't just a psychological problem. They don't eat enough and they don't eat enough for a couple of reasons and boredom is one of them. The food isn't appealing. And that's okay for a short stay on the ISS, but it's really not
她是夏威夷大学的教授。她研究长期太空飞行的心理影响。这是美国宇航局非常重视的一个课题，因为他们希望在未来20年内将宇航员送上火星。宾斯特德的工作是弄清楚如何保持宇航员的健康。她发现无聊不仅仅是一个心理问题。他们吃得不够，他们吃得不够有几个原因，无聊就是其中之一。食物没有吸引力。这对于在国际空间站的短期逗留来说是可以接受的，但对于火星任务的大约两年半时间来说，这绝对是
okay for the two and a half years or so of a Mars mission. That malnutrition could seriously affect astronaut performance. So a few years ago NASA launched a new project. Scientists built this 1200 square foot geodesic dome. It looks like a bubble on the side of a volcano in Hawaii. The idea is to simulate a Martian environment. NASA started setting groups of six volunteers to stay inside the dome for months at a time. Here water is limited. When the volunteers want to see a website, they have to a time. Here water is limited. When the volunteers
不行的。这种营养不良可能会严重影响宇航员的表现。所以几年前美国宇航局发起了一个新项目。科学家建造了这个1200平方英尺的测地穹顶。它看起来像夏威夷火山山坡上的一个气泡。这个想法是模拟火星环境。美国宇航局开始安排六名志愿者组成的团队一次在穹顶内呆上几个月。这里的水是有限的。当志愿者想看某个网站时，他们必须安排时间。这里的水是有限的。当志愿者
want to see a website, they have to submit a request to retrieve the page. And when they want to go outside, they have to put on a space suit. What we looked at out the window was red rock. It was Mars. It looked like Mars. It felt like Mars. It sounded like Mars. We explored lava tubes which are caves created by lava which are also on Mars, and it was a Martian-like environment. Kate Green is a science journalist who spent four months living in this tiny dome with five others. She wrote about her experience in Eon magazine. She says that before she went in, she considered herself a person who never got bored. She says that before she went in, she considered herself a person who never got bored. I go into this mission and I'm pretty sure that I'm not going to be bored.
想看某个网站时，他们必须提交检索该网页的请求。当他们想去外面时，他们必须穿上太空衣。我们从窗户看出去的是红色的岩石。那是火星。它看起来像火星。感觉就像火星。听起来像火星。我们探索了熔岩管，它们是由熔岩形成的洞穴，火星上也有，这是一个类似火星的环境。凯特·格林是一名科学记者，她和另外五个人在这个小穹顶里生活了四个月。她在《永恒》杂志上撰文讲述了自己的经历。她说，在她进去之前，她认为自己是一个从不觉得无聊的人。她说，在她进去之前，她认为自己是一个从不觉得无聊的人。我参加了这个任务，而且我很确信我不会觉得无聊。
Well, things wear on you over the course of four months, and by things I mean a static environment. We were talking to the same five people every single day. Our home was a white dome with puffy walls that didn't really change day to day. But here's the thing, astronauts don't like to admit they get bored. There's a stigma to it because the government is spending literally millions of dollars
好吧，在四个月的时间里，事情会让你感到厌倦，我所说的事物是指一成不变的环境。我们每天都在和同样的五个人说话。我们的家是一个白色的穹顶，墙壁鼓鼓的，日复一日并没有什么真正改变。但问题是，宇航员不喜欢承认他们觉得无聊。这带有耻辱感，因为政府实际上花了几百万美元
to send you into outer space. Even Kim Binsed, the researcher, was reluctant to call it boredom. She says it's a mental lethargy from lack of stimulation, which is like boredom. In addition to all the other scientific research NASA is doing, scientists like Binset have been studying ways to combat boredom. You can't give astronauts hobbies, but you can build variety into their existing routines. One possibility is cooking. Right now, astronauts eat all pre-prepared meals, dehydrated vegetable protein, tortillas,
把你送到外太空。甚至研究人员金·宾塞德也不愿称之为无聊。她说这是一种由于缺乏刺激而产生的精神麻木，这就类似于无聊。除了美国宇航局正在进行的所有其他科学研究外，像宾塞德这样的科学家一直在研究对抗无聊的方法。你不能给宇航员安排爱好，但你可以在他们现有的日常生活中融入多样性。其中一种可能性是烹饪。现在，宇航员吃的所有都是预先准备好的饭菜，脱水植物蛋白，玉米饼，
peanut butter, that sort of thing. Now, if you're an astronaut, a NASA gives you a frozen lasagna for your mission to Mars. It's a lasagna now. It's always going to be a lasagna. Two and a half years from now, it's still alozania. But if I give you pasta and tomato paste powder and some herbs and seasonings and some cheese and maybe some freeze dried meat,
花生酱，诸如此类。现在，如果你是一名宇航员，美国宇航局为你执行火星任务提供了一份冷冻千层面。它现在是一份千层面。它永远都是千层面。从现在起两年半后，它依然是千层面。但如果我给你意大利面、番茄酱粉、一些香料和调味料、一些奶酪，也许还有一些冻干肉，
you can combine those in a bunch of different ways to produce maybe even hundreds of different meals. So that variety means that you get some sensory stimulation from that variety in your food. There's also the creative side, figuring out what best way to combine those ingredients to make them tasty. To be clear, astronauts are not going to be cooking on their way to Mars. You are not going to be cooking in a spaceship. Let me just take that right off the table. The cooking that we're talking about would be on the planetary surface. So Mars has less
你可以把它们以各种不同的方式组合起来，甚至可以做出数百种不同的饭菜。因此，这种多样性意味着你可以从食物的多样性中获得一些感官刺激。还有创意的一面，弄清楚如何以最佳方式将这些食材结合起来，使它们美味可口。需要明确的是，宇航员在去火星的路上不会做饭。你不会在飞船里做饭。让我把这个可能性直接排除。我们所说的烹饪将在行星表面进行。所以火星的重力比地球小
gravity than Earth, but it does have gravity. So that is, you can keep the ingredients in the bowl. Whereas on the space station, your ingredients are gonna float all over the place, and it's just not really possible to cook on the ISS. NASA isn't going to get rid of pre-prepared food altogether. Inside the bubble in Hawaii, Kate Green and the other pseudomarsians
，但它确实有重力。所以也就是说，你可以把食材放在碗里。而在空间站上，你的食材会到处漂浮，在国际空间站上做饭实在是不太可能。美国宇航局不会完全摆脱预制食物。在夏威夷的气泡内，凯特·格林和其他伪火星人
had both pre-prepared food and raw ingredients. On their cooking days they got pretty creative. They actually had a contest where people outside the bubble could recommend recipes. They made a kind of sushi using spam, patties out of flour and canned salmon, and a crater crunch bar with quinoa flakes and macadamia nuts. And cooking didn't just increase the variety of their diets. So many interesting things happen when you're preparing a meal, especially with other people. Cooking is truly a social experience. I remember I had a number of great cooking experiences with everyone on the crew. Actually, everyone had such different styles. And so it was a time when
既有预制食物，也有生鲜食材。在他们的烹饪日，他们变得非常有创意。他们实际上举办了一场比赛，气泡外的人可以推荐食谱。他们用午餐肉制作了一种寿司，用面粉和罐头三文鱼制作了肉饼，还用藜麦片和澳洲坚果制作了陨石坑脆皮棒。烹饪不仅增加了他们饮食的多样性。当你准备一餐时，会发生很多有趣的事情，尤其是和其他人一起。烹饪确实是一种社交体验。我记得我和船上的每个人都有过很多美好的烹饪经历。实际上，每个人的风格都非常不同。所以那是一个
even if I wasn't working with people in a scientific way or with any of our projects, I worked with everyone in the kitchen. And that was, you really got to know a person's personality and attitude and I really enjoyed that part of it. Now there are other benefits to sending astronauts to Mars with ingredients rather than pre-prepared meals. Cooking with ingredients can be healthier. It weighs less to send the food this way, but there are costs, more equipment, more energy, and more astronaut time.
即使我没有以科学的方式或与我们的任何项目一起与人们工作，我也在厨房里与每个人一起工作的时刻。那是，你真的能了解一个人的个性和态度，我真的很喜欢那一部分。现在，用食材而不是预制餐食将宇航员送往火星还有其他好处。用食材烹饪可以更健康。用这种方式运送食物重量更轻，但也有成本，需要更多的设备、更多的能量和更多的宇航员时间。
There are more important things to do on Mars than make a homemade lasagna. But, instead of finding the psychological benefits are worth the trade-off. If you look at the same things every day, if you eat the same things every day, if you hear the same things every day, it can produce some negative psychological effects. The creativity of making food and the way you can use the same set of ingredients in different ways to reduce different meals, that those things were very psychologically important to the crew. NASA is running its fourth and final pseudomars mission in Hawaii now.
在火星上有比做一份自制千层面更重要的事情要做。但是，宾塞德发现心理益处权衡之下是值得的。如果你每天都看着相同的东西，如果你每天都吃相同的东西，如果你每天都听到相同的东西，它就会产生一些负面的心理影响。制作食物的创意以及你可以用同一套食材以不同方式制作不同餐食的方法，这些对机组人员来说在心理上非常重要。美国宇航局目前正在夏威夷进行其第四次也是最后一次伪火星任务。
Volunteers will be there an entire year. That's Max Nestrak. You can learn more about the pseudomars missions by going to highc's.org that's h i dash s e a s dot org. Coming up, Daniel Pink is here to play Stop What Science With Me. We're going to talk about the pernicious effects of boredom in our lives. Stay with us. Back now for another round of stopwatch science, I'm Shankar Vedanthan. I'm joined as always by Daniel Pink.
志愿者将在那里待上一整年。那是马克斯·内斯特拉克。你可以通过访问 highc's.org 了解更多关于伪火星任务的信息，即 h i dash s e a s dot org。接下来，丹尼尔·平克将在这里与我一起玩“停止科学”游戏。我们将讨论无聊对我们生活的有害影响。请继续收听。欢迎回来进行新一轮的“秒表科学”，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。和往常一样，丹尼尔·平克也加入了我的行列。
He's been variously called the love guru and the divorce doctor But on this show his primary title is senior stopwatch science correspondent. Welcome dad. I thank you, Shankar on Stopwatch science dad and I give one another 60 seconds to summarize interesting social science research as we approach the 60 second mark Our producers will bring up the music to drown us out just like they do at the Oscars and they have itchy fingers so they are dying to do this. Our topic today is boredom. Now, I often feel like my life is one long struggle to avoid being bored. I hate being bored. Are you the same Dan? Only when I'm with you strangely.
他曾被称为爱情大师和离婚医生。但在这个节目中，他的主要头衔是“秒表科学”资深记者。欢迎丹。谢谢你，尚卡尔，作为“秒表科学”的搭档，我和对方有60秒的时间来总结有趣的社会科学研究，当我们接近60秒大关时，我们的制作人会播放音乐把我们的声音盖过去，就像他们在奥斯卡颁奖典礼上做的那样，他们手指发痒，所以他们急于这么做。我们今天的主题是无聊。现在，我经常觉得我的生活是一场漫长的斗争，为了避免感到无聊。我讨厌无聊。丹，你也一样吗？奇怪的是，只有当我和你在一起时才是这样。
Yeah, I don't understand it. Is that because you're talking to me or because you're listening to yourself? I'm not sure. So today we're going to talk about the effects of boredom and the lengths we're willing to go to avoid being bored. Dan, if you're ready, your 4.60 seconds starts now. Okay, this research published in Personality and Social Psychology Bulletin takes us to Ireland where a bitter history has left some Irish with a negative view of the English.
是的，我不明白。是因为你在跟我说话，还是因为你在听你自己说话？我不太确定。所以今天我们要讨论无聊的影响以及我们为了避免无聊而愿意付出的努力。丹，如果你准备好了，你的4.60秒现在开始。好的，这项发表在《个性与社会心理学公报》上的研究把我们带到了爱尔兰，那里痛苦的历史给一些爱尔兰人留下了对英国人的负面看法。
Researchers gathered Irish university students and cafe goers and divided them into two groups. One group, they bored the heck out of by making them count tiny boxes on computer screens or draw lines on paper for a very long time. The other group did the same tasks, but only briefly. Then they had participants play judge. Researchers presented a hypothetical case about an Englishman beating up an Irishman and asked participants what prison sentence they'd impose. Those who were deeply bored imposed far longer sentences than those who weren't bored. Then researchers reversed the scenario, and Irishman beats up an Englishman.
研究人员聚集了爱尔兰大学生和咖啡馆顾客，并将他们分成两组。其中一组，他们让他们长时间数电脑屏幕上的小方格或在纸上画线，无聊透顶。另一组做同样的任务，但时间很短。然后他们让参与者扮演法官。研究人员提出了一个关于英国人殴打爱尔兰人的假设案例，并询问参与者他们会判处多少刑期。那些深感无聊的人判处的刑期要远远长于那些不觉得无聊的人。然后研究人员颠倒了情景，爱尔兰人殴打英国人。
This time the bored people gave their fellow Irishman a shorter sentence than people who weren't bored. Board of some scientists say creates a feeling of meaninglessness. When we feel things are meaningless, we seek meaning, and one way we do that is by aligning more closely with our own tribe and discriminating against those we perceive as outsiders. So that's really interesting. What you're saying is that the more bored the Irish volunteer's got, the more willing they were
这一次，无聊的人给他们的爱尔兰同胞判处的刑期比不觉得无聊的人要短。一些科学家说，无聊会产生一种毫无意义的感觉。当我们觉得事情毫无意义时，我们就会寻求意义，而我们做到这一点的方法之一就是更紧密地与我们自己的部落保持一致，并对我们认为的外人进行歧视。所以这真的很有趣。你的意思是，爱尔兰志愿者越无聊，他们就越愿意
to give English defendants a longer sentence and Irish defendants a shorter sentence. Precisely. And the people who weren't bored, though, they gave the English and the Irish similar sentences. But there's something about being bored that makes us feel a lack of meaning. And one way way unfortunately,
给英国被告判处更长的刑期，给爱尔兰被告判处更短的刑期。正是如此。然而，不觉得无聊的人给英国人和爱尔兰人判处的刑期相似。但无聊的某种特质让我们感到缺乏意义。而不幸的是，途径之一是，
the human being seek meaning is by affiliating with the in-group and discriminating against an out-group. So do you think this has applications in the criminal justice system? Perhaps. I mean, I think that if you've ever been on a jury, jury service is often quite boring. And what this paper made me wonder is,
人类寻求意义的方式是通过归属于内群体并歧视外群体。所以你认为这在刑事司法系统中有什么应用吗？也许吧。我的意思是，我认为如果你曾经担任过陪审团成员，陪审团服务通常相当无聊。这篇论文让我好奇的是，
is being so bored serving on a jury, introducing bias, even more bias into the criminal justice system. But interesting question, let's go to you, Shankar, for our next one, your 60 seconds starts right now. All right. I think that last study done was by Wynon Van Tilburg. Yes.
在陪审团任职期间感到如此无聊，是否正在将偏见，甚至是更多的偏见引入刑事司法系统？但这是一个有趣的问题，让我们转向你，尚卡尔，进入下一个问题，你的60秒现在开始。好的。我想上一项研究是维农·范·蒂尔伯格做的。是的。
Van Tilburg seems to be very interested in boring stuff because I came by another study he did about boredom in 2013. Along with Eric Igou, Van Tilburg asked people to copy boring passages from Wikipedia on how you mix cement. Good Lord. I can just imagine Van Tilburg sitting in his office and dreaming up new ways to make people bored.
范·蒂尔伯格似乎对无聊的事情非常感兴趣，因为我偶然看到了他在2013年做的另一项关于无聊的研究。范·蒂尔伯格与埃里克·伊古一起，让人们从维基百科上抄写关于如何搅拌水泥的无聊段落。天哪。我简直可以想象范·蒂尔伯格坐在办公室里梦想着用新方法让人感到无聊。
Anyway, the more bored volunteers get when you ask them to think about a memory, Van Tilburg and Iggo find board volunteers end up into nostalgic thinking, nostalgic memories. Now, I have to say I don't find this particularly counterintuitive. Many of us have seen this happen, but I do wonder if this explains why many artists and creative thinkers say that being bored is a useful thing.
无论如何，当志愿者被要求回想起一段记忆时，他们变得越无聊，范·蒂尔伯格和伊古发现，无聊的志愿者最终会陷入怀旧的思考、怀旧的记忆中。现在，我必须说，我并不觉得这特别违背直觉。我们许多人都见过这种情况发生，但我确实想知道这是否能解释为什么许多艺术家和创意思想家说感到无聊是一件有用的事。
Bordom can put us in a state of mind that's open to daydreaming, imagination, and creativity. Very interesting. Do you think this has to do with meaning too? That we're feeling meaningless and so we go back in our lives and say, oh, that great home run I hid in Little League or the day I got married. Not to equate those two. You get the idea. I just want to know, Dan, this segment is not being edited and your wife is going to be hearing this.
无聊可以让我们进入一种对白日梦、想象力和创造力开放的心态。非常有趣。你认为这也与意义有关吗？我们感到毫无意义，所以我们回顾生活并说：“哦，我在少儿棒球联盟击出的那个棒球本垒打，或者我结婚的那天。”不是要把这两者等同起来。你懂我的意思。我只想知道，丹，这一段没有被剪辑，你妻子会听到这个的。
Yeah, well, fortunately I've never hit a home run in Little League, so that's a complete fantasy, not nostalgia. But I think you're right. I think it does have something to do with meaninglessness, and sort of the drive to find meaning, and how we drift to what that kind of thinking when we're bored. All right, Dan, if you're ready, your next 60 seconds starts right now. Okay, so how much do we hate being bored? That's the question a team of researchers led by Timothy Wilson of the University of Virginia answered in the prestigious journal Science. In 11 experiments they confirmed that we really don't like being left alone in an empty
是的，好吧，幸运的是我从未在少儿棒球联盟击出过本垒打，所以那完全是幻想，而不是怀旧。但我认为你是对的。我认为这确实与毫无意义感有关，某种程度上是对寻找意义的驱使，以及当我们感到无聊时，我们是如何倾向于那种思考方式的。好的，丹，如果你准备好了，你的下一个60秒现在开始。好的，那么我们有多讨厌无聊呢？这就是弗吉尼亚大学的蒂莫西·威尔逊领导的研究团队在著名期刊《科学》上回答的问题。他们在11项实验中证实，我们确实不喜欢独自留在空荡荡的
room even for just 15 minutes with nothing but our own thoughts. But one of these experiments was rather shocking. Researchers put participants in one of their unadorned rooms, asked them to do nothing except think, but get this, offered them the option of giving themselves painful electric shocks. One quarter of the women and two-thirds of the men chose to shock themselves at least once.
房间里，哪怕只有15分钟，除了我们自己的想法之外什么也没有。但其中一个实验相当令人震惊。研究人员将参与者放入其中一个朴素的房间里，要求他们除了思考之外什么也不做，但你听着，他们提供了给自己电击的选项。四分之一的女性和三分之二的男性选择对自己进行了至少一次电击。
One guy in fact, shocked himself, 190 times, which is just kind of weird. In other words, simply being alone with their own thoughts for 15 minutes was so horrifying, so terrifyingly boring that many prefer to harm themselves. Self-administering electric shocks was less painful than just being bored. Well, that is an amazing study, Dan.
事实上，有一个家伙给自己电击了190次，这简直有点诡异。换句话说，仅仅独自带着自己的想法呆上15分钟是如此可怕，如此令人厌烦，以至于许多人宁愿伤害自己。自我实施电击也比仅仅感到无聊痛苦要小。嗯，那是一项了不起的研究，丹。
And do you know what the voltage was on these shocks? I have no idea, but I know that it was painful because they also tested, and they found out that these participants said they would pay to avoid these shocks, and yet when they were bored, they brought them on. In other words, they would actually be willing to pay even more to avoid being bored.
你知道这些电击的电压是多少吗？我不知道，但我知道这是痛苦的，因为他们也进行了测试，他们发现这些参与者表示他们愿意付钱来避免这些电击，然而当他们感到无聊时，他们却主动接受了电击。换句话说，为了避免无聊，他们实际上甚至愿意支付更多的钱。
That's what it sounds like, which just seems crazy. So Shankar, you're next. Here's your 60 seconds. Starts right now. All right. This is one of my favorite stories about how much we hate to be bored. Richard Larsen at MIT tells a story about how business passengers arriving on early morning flights into Houston were complaining about being bored as they waited for the conveyor
听起来是这样的，这简直太疯狂了。所以尚卡尔，轮到你了。这是你的60秒。现在开始。好的。这是我最喜欢的故事之一，关于我们有多么讨厌无聊。麻省理工学院的理查德·拉尔森讲述了一个故事，关于乘早班航班抵达休斯顿的商务旅客抱怨在等待行李传送
belt to bring their bags. The airline company brought in consultants, they hired baggage handlers, they reduced the waiting time to eight minutes max. Nothing worked, the complaints kept coming in. So the airline thought harder, executives realized that business passengers was spending only a couple of minutes disembarking from the plane and six or seven minutes waiting in baggage claim. The solution, they move the arrival gate further from baggage claim. Passengers now spend six or seven minutes walking to baggage claim and one or two minutes waiting for their bags. Poof, the complaints disappeared. Extraordinary. I mean, this goes to, there's a concept called
带运送行李时感到无聊。航空公司请来了顾问，雇用了行李搬运工，将等待时间缩短到最多八分钟。什么都没用，投诉还是不断涌现。所以航空公司进行了更深入的思考，高管们意识到商务旅客花在下飞机上的时间只有几分钟，而在行李提取处等待的时间则有六到七分钟。解决方案是，他们把到达口搬得离行李提取处更远。现在旅客需要花六到七分钟步行去行李提取处，花一到两分钟等待行李。砰，投诉消失了。太非凡了。我的意思是，这涉及到一个概念，叫做
Occupied Time, where if our time is occupied, we don't feel a sense of distress. So we'll take more occupied time instead of a shorter amount of time that is an occupied. I love that. It is fastening. But you should never check your bags. All right. So there you have it. Boredom can make you prejudiced.
占用时间，如果我们的时间被占用了，我们就不会感到痛苦。所以我们宁愿选择更多被占用的时间，也不愿选择较短的未被占用的时间。我喜欢这样。这太吸引人了。但你永远不应该托运行李。好了。所以你们看到了。无聊会让你产生偏见。
It can make you nostalgic. Completely pointless activities can reduce your feelings of boredom. But here's the most important takeaway. If you find yourself bored and asking yourself whether you should stick your finger in that electrical socket nearby, please don't. Instead, go listen to all the additions of stop-what science and Dan and I promise to keep you entertained. Dan, thank you for joining me today.
它会让你感到怀旧。完全无意义的活动可以减少你的无聊感。但最重要的一点是：如果你发现自己感到无聊，并问自己是否应该把手指插进附近那个插座里，请不要这样做。相反，去听所有版本的“停止科学”，我和丹向你保证会让你觉得有趣。丹，谢谢你今天加入我。
Thank you, Shankar. Thank you, Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢你，尚卡尔。谢谢尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这里是美国国家公共电台。这个插曲还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。